[Musique]
ils ont réussi leur pari construire un
exemplaire de la vis aérienne mais cinq
siècles plus tôt de l'imagination génial
de léonard de vinci
[Musique]
[Rires]
un mois plus tôt à l'atelier de
métallerie du lycée jean lurçat c'est la
course contre la montre
pierre chauvin fait le va et vient entre
deux cours pour contrôler les pièces
moment ils doivent une épaisseur de 15
mm ça fait 15 ans qu'on dit m donc il y
aura 25 siècles à se promener à des
films et c'est là que ça devient
intéressant que voilà et puis pour les
élèves voire la contrainte du délai qui
qui pointe son nez tout doucement là
donc on sent on sent qu'on est vraiment
dans des conditions d'une entreprise on
va terminer directement la fabrication
fait du des principales lens où neil des
principales en fait il va au centre ils
vont au centre directement fait du
d'armature et c'est ça qui va contenir
le tube carrés qui va permettre à
l'hélice en fait de tourner autour en
fait voilà qu'on travaille dans
l'urgence mais bon on sera dans les
temps heureusement que j'ai des élèves
en fait qu'ils ont réalisé leur stage
dessus on fait des aides de tpm des
terminales ces apps et qui aurait dû
aller quatre semaines en stage en
entreprise
j'ai gardé exprès là on attaquera ya
70 à 80 % de taux de
finition
julien finalisent les soudures dumas de
la vis construire un prototype c'est une
première pour lui l'occasion d'apprendre
à travailler en équipe de l'activité
s'il y en a un qui part faire une pièce
ailleurs et ben il peut tout faussé du
couffo tout ce qu'on travaille ensemble
et
comme une famille il faut pas parler
c'est un dans l'eau sinon il va faire
n'importe quoi et ça peut retarder de
cet atelier sortira la plus haute vis du
monde jamais réalisée d'après le croquis
de léonard de vinci
lavisse aérienne s'inscrit dans la série
de machines volantes que le génie
italien a dessiné entre 480 7 et 14 190
grand observateur de la nature adeptes
avant l'heure du biomimétisme
parmi tous les rêves de léonard il y
avait celui de voler
donc il veut commencer
cinq siècles plus tard les élèves en
métallerie apprennent à naviguer dans la
structure de la vis grâce à un programme
de réalité virtuelle
la violence va
je rentre carrément dans le dans la vis
et je peux voir légal et tout ça sans
forcément est en planque où p our
autrement on voit la couleur on voit la
différence des matériaux pour la
fabrication ça permet de concrétiser les
pièces qu'on fait ici voir à quoi ça
ressemble qu'est ce que tu vois ce
programme de réalité virtuelle c'est
pierre chauvin qu'il a conçu une
innovation dans l'art d'enseigner que
l'éducation nationale souhaite étendre à
l'ensemble des établissements français
est à deux autres de chaque côté je te
recommande c'est déjà pas vraiment du
futur pour tous les enseignants vie oui
avec ça on va pouvoir faire du jeu vidéo
c'est à dire qu'on va pouvoir voilà
aucun moment on a dit que l'école ça
devait être embêtant mais que ce n'est
pas là pour être bientôt l'école c'est
fait pour apprendre des choses que si on
peut apprendre devenir du dic je pense
que c'est beaucoup plus intéressant pour
tout le monde plutôt que de forcer les
gens à utiliser encore des méthodes
qu'on utilise avant parce qu'on n'avait
pas les technologies modernes
[Musique]
les plans de la vi ont été réalisés ici
à l'école polytech d'orléans par six
élèves ingénieurs
[Musique]
on partait vraiment juste un plan de
léonard de vinci il y avait rien qui
avait été fait avant mais c'est ça aussi
ce qui est bien ce texte est un projet
vierge ce qui est vachement agréable
c'est que justement le fait que ce soit
de la z c'est qu'on puisse concrétiser
certaines choses qui ont été faits par
un intrigant familial comme son besoin
donc de tout ça c'est vrai que ça a fait
un projet assez atypique léonard de
vinci avait marqué dans le codex que
l'extrémité de la vie ce soit un câble
de faire de la grosseur d'une corde et
que du centre cercle il y ait une vie
brasse
on a eu besoin de deux cerveaux pendant
au moins une semaine pour faire les
papiers à l'avant effectivement c'est
dur à mettre en place sur un logiciel 3d
même à notre époque en 2019 donc voila
mais ça se fait très bien on a réussi
avec la validation derrière par nos
professeurs qui nous ont cas tout au
long du des heures allouées sur ce
projet
bonjour le grand ordonnateur de la vis
c'est lui
jean-pierre ans qu'ils y professeur de
mathématiques
bonjour tout va bien
je pense qu'il ya des soucis quand même
et le souci aujourd'hui ce sont les deux
moteurs censés élevé la vis et ses 850
kg c'est plus de deux fois la charge
initialement prévu on avait un souci
parce que les deux moteurs tiennent dans
une cage
cette cage on a vu que esthétiquement
impose un problème et on a dû plusieurs
fois la redimensionner la modifier
est-ce que vous avez travaillé là dessus
on allonge je dis à m claquage et du
coup on peut voir entrer à la fois les
deux moteurs et les éléments de
transmission
de manière assez compact tout en
équilibrant les masses le concept c'est
quand même le concept précurseur de
l'hélicoptère s'était juste en fait le
début de l' idée il manquait en bout il
manque un le côté d'un moteur mais aussi
il faut un moteur un peu dans l'autre
sens pour comme dans le cas des
hélicoptères donc c'était c'était une
bonne idée elle était juste peut-être
pas abouti
de l'autre côté des alpes à florence non
loin de l'endroit où est né leonardo
leurs alter ego de l'école d'ingénieurs
ont été chargé e de concevoir la voilure
de la machine
[Musique]
dévoile conçue en italie est fabriqué en
france ici dans les faubourgs d'orléans
[Musique]
dans cet atelier installé au sous sol de
la maison familiale loïse coupe etc ou
les panneaux de la voilure
[Musique]
donc c'est super voilà là on nage et
finissent à
comment on fait du coup pour la ronde 10
et surtout pour les bouts
jean-pierre assez le maître d'oeuvre de
la vis une réalisation dont il a eu
l'idée à son arrivée à orléans et
comment ça va se mettre en tension se
fait ici là ça va pas rester droit je
vais dessiner
la ronde des corps peut-être qui est l
élément déclencheur pour ça c'est plus
dans ma vie personnelle c'est que voilà
notre fils aux 10 à jour on a appris
qu'elle avait greffé et je lui ai écrit
sur un bout de serviette sur un coin de
table dans un café que je lui ferais un
spectacle en fait ce spectacle c'est pas
tout à fait ce que j'ai fait je me suis
plutôt orienté vers une exposition une
exposition sur le thème de renaissance
mais renaissance avec un s et parmi les
renaissance que va fêter la région
centre val de loire qui a fêté la france
va fêter l'italie il ya notre petite
renaissance familiale qui tient du fait
que la grève de lui s'est très bien
passé ça nous a changé la vie ça lui a
changé la vie et voilà donc je sais un
petit tout est mêlé que j'ai envie de
dire tout est mêlé
loïse a pu mener à bien son bac pro de
couture elle a entrepris de tailler les
voiles de la vis dans un coton d'egypte
très dense de couleur écru identique à
celui utilisé au xvème siècle mon
challenge c'est que je fais
de la coupe industriel mais
en version
artisanale voilà c'est ça je mélange de
technique
et je mélange du coup mes 2 mai deux
apprentissages
il
c'est à moi aussi qu'elle comble à
responsabilités vrai que ça tienne que
ce soit bien fait que ce soit comme ils
veulent et c'est à dire que ce soit bien
entendu tout ça
le l'intérêt de mettre des scratchs et
qu'ils puissent eux tendre et ajuster la
machine parce que concrètement moi je
n'ai pas vu la vraie film voilà je fais
avec les informations qu'on veut
[Musique]
nous sommes j - 4 avant la grande
exposition de la vis à orléans à la cité
des métiers les ébénistes fabrique les
ultimes habillage de la vis des poignets
du cabestan réalisé avec du chêne façon
renaissance
c'est le style qui fait la charnière
vraiment entre le moyen âge et l'époque
monarchique peu tout le monde connaît
avec louis 15 louis saez les beaux
meubles on s'est vraiment l'époque
charnière où où on sort du coffre
brut on arrive à un meuble
et les ébénistes au xvème siècle faisait
appel à un ingrédient bien spéciale
l'huile de coude
c'était l'huile de coude c'était un tour
comme ça
qui est régulé qui tourne toujours à la
même vitesse qui tient parfaitement le
morceau de bois c'est n'existaient pas
c'était tout à la main
c'était ce qu'il faudrait ça c'est le
fraiser
quand on met un coup de force pour
friser puis qu'on puisse mettre une vis
qui soit adaptée jean-louis chemin
enseigne l'ébénisterie depuis 20 ans au
centre de formation des apprentis
ici le projet d'habillage de la vi a
suscité tout de suite l' enthousiasme
qui est intéressant sur le fond et sur
la forme c'est à dire que nous on était
centre de formation et que bien
évidemment tout le monde était impliqué
compris nos apprentis nos propres
apprentis du centre de formation donc
ils se sont appliqués sur ce projet on a
fait quelques recherches aussi puisqu'en
fait on rebondit aussi sur l'histoire du
style c'est à dire que toute cette
période renaissance on est reparti sur
un cabestan de bateaux pour essayer de
2,2 de renouer aussi avec le temps passé
et tous les éléments
essentiel de cette période
direction maintenant la collégiale
saint-pierre le pus ailier d'orléans où
jean louis et benoît vont rêver une
partie de la visage sur la vis
les magnifiques
as tu es content c'est bien les mecs
sont super
[Musique]
il reste encore beaucoup à faire avant
l'inauguration
ça va aller on est on est dans les
délais il nous restera plus que la
partie cabestan la partie supérieure qui
n'est pas monté sur la structure c'est
en cours nous allons certainement
d'installer deux membres
j - avant l'ouverture de l'exposition
laury's procèdent aux derniers
ajustements sur les voiles comme pour un
défilé de mode
mais là je suis un peu à la bourre
forcément
il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à retravailler c'est en fait
c'est du sûr nous
rapporte lui le cerclage de la vie ce
qui a dû être recruté dans l'urgence
donc bien soudé des pièces et bien ceux
des femmes
sinon quand on assemble après il ya
toujours des petits écarts et c'est la
mise au point
[Musique]
place à la phase d'essai la vie s'élève
les deux moteurs vont ils supporter la
charge de 850 kg
marche très très bien elle tourne elle
monte elle descend c'est ce qu'on
voulait donner une âme en fait à nîmes
et donner une âme ce que léonard voulait
quand il nous a dit mes machines il leur
manque quelque chose c'est l'âme des
oiseaux l'âme pour voler une mécanique
de la vie qui aura demandé près d'un an
de conception et de fabrication
la plus haute vie ça et rien au monde
porte une aventure technologique et
humaine qui aurait séduit léonard de
vinci lui qui place l'homme au coeur de
ses réflexions
[Musique]